the las vegas valley water district says
it has a solution to our continued
drought on the colorado river that's
right it's a new tool called ami and
we're told it will help customers manage
their water usage more efficiently
it definitely brings the temperature
down ace anderson has been living in las
vegas for more than 20 years and takes
pride in her home and all the greenery
around it we've thought about doing turf
so at least it's still green we have
thought about it but i just think it
takes away from this neighborhood
[Music]
as water conservation increases across
the valley corey enis with the las vegas
valley water district says they are
rolling out a new 20 million dollar tool
called advanced meter infrastructure to
help its customers make smarter water
choices it will give us the ability to
get meter reads on a daily basis as
opposed to having trucks roll out to get
that information once a month water
officials say the system is 80 percent
complete with an expected launch of
spring 2023 while ami promises to be
more efficient for the utility company
they say it will also provide benefits
for customers without them having to
worry about installing anything giving
them the ability to set limits on usage
to get leaked notifications and to get
information real time and how they're
using water at their property ina says
there will be no cost to customers and
has been funded by previous rates right
now watering on sundays is prohibited
and mandatory watering restrictions is
in full effect between 11am and 7 pm
daily restrictions anderson says reflect
our grim reality is it fair i don't
think it's very fair but i mean
it's our choice to keep it
water officials tell us the system is
becoming industry standard around the
country and water investigations will
continue as normal they said customers
will be able to learn more about it as
we get closer to launch